[Music]
everybody so welcome to another lesson
of chess in psychology for this week we
are gonna look at hopefully one and a
half one and a half game of mine and the
other half is endgame and we'll continue
it in our next lesson which is right
after this one the intense and endgame
which that should also be available on
YouTube just a different link so yeah
hopefully there will be pretty nice both
of these games are in 2015 2015 2016 was
when I got my norms and these were
pretty intense tournaments for me and it
was pretty nice that I was beating
higher rated so hopefully how I prepared
to get to that and how I prepared the
game might help you preparing for your
own preparations in the tournaments so
let's get started this game was against
John SIA
she is pretty strong
and she was a better chess player at
this game
she still is and this is in World Junior
2015 she was she have like seven out of
seven in that tournament and the
tournament is 13 round long and I
believe I was playing against her around
11 she ended up winning the tournament
but not this game all right let's get
into it so she's a pretty she hurt sorry
in in this specific tournament she loved
playing real apes' and I do believe that
she is a very she loves playing real
opens in general something might have
changed but drew Lopez is one of those
super classic chess that everybody plays
in higher higher levels so after Bishop
e5 yeah so there are many many moves
that black can do the the usual ones are
Berlin with night of six or a six that
follows later with night of six some
unusual ones are the d6 and g6 and they
are very playable there they have been
played in super grand master level chest
and so for this specific game I prepared
against her the move f5 which is called
Janish it hasn't another name to but I
learned it as a honest and I mainly did
this because I saw that she had bad
results against this and she didn't it
didn't feel like she know it in depth as
much as I did I had prepared this
beforehand before the tournament but I
wasn't really planning on playing it so
I played it specifically against this
opponent so that's something that you
can try if you play with someone enough
or you have the time to prepare against
and you can
to find out what weaknesses do they have
and go after them switch
especially in opening d3 is one of the
main lines the other lines that could be
considered is Knight c3 there is taking
there's Bishop c6 but the two main lines
are d3 and Knight c3 so she went for d3
after the the pawns exchanged you can
immediately feel that blacks hopefully
gonna try to do short Castle black would
want to have this bishop in this
diagonal because the bishop in this di
diagonal would be very strong attacking
f2 and it's such an open diagonal you
know that this lines definitely gonna
want to be on f6 so that's something
that you already have a very clear plan
so after Knight f6 Castle Bishop c5 yeah
so you you have a clear idea if you have
one more move you are going to try and
do short Castle as black and after short
Castle you have a very nice flow of
ideas you want to play d6 you want to
bring your Bishop out you have so much
more space and it just it's such a nice
flow so after Bishop d3 after Queen c5 I
gave up the answer queen d3 is one of
the main ideas that prevents making
short castle because now short castle
there's the Queen c4 and your Bishop is
hanging so it's temporary preventing
black from making short castle
so another how do you think black can
proceed should black keep fighting to
try and play short castle with moves
such as d6 or do you see anything else
I'm sorry I can't hear you
still can't hear you I'm so sorry
Oh
um
maybe
what do you think about a move like 94
for black
I really can't hear you I'm so sorry
okay-y
he says don't move Knight to d5 you
thought you were saying 95 yeah I'm
talking about 94 so you would be
attacking the bishop and you're not
directly trying to actually make sure it
cast off as white is trying to prevent
it
yeah that's that's your idea if 94 you
are going to try and capture the b5
Bishop because okay
all right great yeah there you could try
and play something like these six and
maybe follow it with something like
Queenie seven and Bishop e6 and try to
make short Castle but at least at the
time 94 was a stronger idea both bye-bye
engines and bye just human eye because
it's it's it keeps you game more active
if you play d6 you're playing passively
because you need to spend another move
trying to play Queen d7 Bishop e6 and
you don't have that nice flow anymore so
94 is the right move
and so if black if it was black to move
again black would most likely try to
take on b5 so that's why the Knights
would get exchanged here ideally and so
this Bishop on d4 is pretty strong
Wyatt is kind of tied up white can't
really move this Bishop to g5 per se
because of the b2 pawn so 992 doesn't
really make much sense because I'm gonna
try and make castle now because the
bishop is protected and so the why try
to kick this [ __ ] about c3 and Bishop
c5 it doesn't really serve any purpose
for what for black because the bishop
was on c5 few moves ago and it was it
would be under attack after castle and
Queen c4 regardless
so after c3 Bishop comes back to b6
it's generally also a good idea
especially for beginners intermediates
players not to leave their pieces
hangings like if he would play Bishop c5
it gives you more chances to blunder and
just you might forget about it so that's
something that I also try not to do in
my rapid and blitz games I try not to
leave my pieces hanging I always try to
have them protected by something and it
usually prevents blunders so after we
should be six I'm gonna try and do short
castle so white has to keep fighting for
me not to do short castle because if I
do play this short castle I still have a
pretty easy position and the rook on f8
and the bishop won't be six with piece
looking at f2 so she wins for Bishop c4
to prevent my casting and after that I
have this idea to try and still play
these six maybe I'm try and play Queen
sees Queen e7 with idea Bishop e6 maybe
to keep pushing for short cast off but I
actually remembered that I have looked
at this position before the game not
specifically to prepare it just because
it was question for myself that's well
what am I gonna do in this position and
I do remember that in my before the game
analysis I reached the position that I
didn't make sure didn't make any castle
and I kept my King on eh and had a rook
just to f8 to just develop the rook so I
I was mentally okay with not cancelling
going into the
position and going into this game so I
feel like that's something that if you
didn't know that computer approves of
you not castling it might have been a
little hard psychologically not to want
to castle so yeah here she started
pushing a little on the queenside which
was pretty smart because it takes away
my any idea that I might have from
making like long cast off and also wants
to play a five and grab my Bishop so I
played a five there is there's this
little difference between a five and a
six that usually players don't pay
enough attention to if you would go a
six most likely would would face
something like this and it just gives
way too much space to go out to white
and white has ideas to start attacking
your Queen side pretty immediately
whereas when you play a five even though
it serves the same purpose that you're
opening the a7 Square for your Bishop
now it means that if something like
before it might before might even be not
such a good move you can take it you can
bring you can like take it maybe and
then do something like Bishop d4 again
attack the rook you have more ideas and
your position is not so tangled anymore
so in the game I played a five she
continued to add visual g5 yeah
and in at this point in my game I did
realize that yeah I'm not gonna be able
to do castle anymore
i I was okay with that but so knowing
that you don't you're not gonna do short
cast oh what's the move you would do in
this position
yeah yeah that's that's one of the moves
that's coming up but these how do you
feel about the bishop on g5 do you like
it there do you want it to go away
yeah you're like questioning the
validates the validity I have problems
pronouncing this have this bishop if you
play h6 well after you page six the
bishop going to h4 is not a real thing
because Bishop h4 you're just gonna move
forward with g5 and this bishop has to
go to g3 and this just looks like a tall
palm to me doesn't really do much here
so another thing to consider after such
moves of h6 is after T if if your
opponent to take the knight your queen
is way more useful here you want it your
Queen to develop you you have this
strong bishop here Queen here you're
gonna do to get faith next move and
you're going for this pawn so another
thing is when your opponent plays Bishop
g5 psychologically you kind of don't
want it to be there so you kind of wanna
you want to know where is this Bishop
like want to go and playing a move like
h6 might give your opponents the chance
to make the mistake where as if when you
play rook f8 your opponent's wouldn't be
so inclined to move the bishop for a
second time so page six
so after having said that where do you
think your whites bishop should go
you want to go all the way back to
detail what would you do with the white
night then
okay so you are thinking about Bishop d2
and then you're gonna try and regroup
your pieces at night a3 and that's it
yeah it's there is nothing wrong with
this should be to accept the fact that
keeps my strong Bishop over here so
another way to think about it again just
psychologically without having to
calculate it is objectively my bishop on
b6 is stronger than your Bishop on g5 so
try to exchange it off as white I would
I mean as black I would love to keep
this bishop but I can't anymore so not
even if Bishop d2 serves a higher
purpose Bishop e3 is going to annoy me
really like I don't want to exchange
this Bishop and I have to now so yeah I
do have to take on e3 because if I don't
then you're gonna take my bishop and
then this pawn structure is really not
what you want to play so Bishop e3 Queen
takes III now even though the he what
she managed to take off my strong Bishop
off the board created some other
weaknesses see this is a weakness that
if the knight gets there it's already
unleashing so many attacks and squares
and so many weaknesses so many ideas so
the first thing that you should realize
is this so after every exchange it's a
good idea to think about so what's
different now
and the big thing that's different is I
don't have that much pressure on f2
squared whereas I have access to this f4
square so in this situation what do you
want to do do you think it's a good idea
to start off with 935 and try to jump to
f4 or do you want to try and do
something else to prepare for it's
better is there anything wrong with
minus five actually
yeah I am talking I'm talking about this
maneuver just because the night would be
very much stronger there and it would be
attacking least double G 2 so I'm asking
if it's a good idea to play Knight edge
5 immediately or do you want to try and
prepare this idea more
okay so you want to do it straight to
her yeah I don't I don't think there is
anything that's like wrong with nidus
five but for me I wanted to prepare it
more and that's why I played with 27 I
was still considering something like
Bishop e6 and honestly in the game I was
a little I didn't really I didn't want
to deal with something the idea of the
Queen f3 even though I do have Knight f4
it still gives I feel like it gives
unnecessary complications I might have a
different opinion if I was playing it
right now but I just wanted to have it
more prepared
so I played 27 I still hold this Bishop
e6 idea and I'm protecting this f7
square from any possible 9s v Queen of
trees
yeah that's an idea I'm I haven't I was
still undecided on if I do want to click
it should be six and maybe Castille or
not sure it's gay I stole because I
still do have the option of short cast
so it's not illegal yet so she played
Queen t3 I didn't really understand this
move honestly I think she thought I was
going for Bishop e6 so she just wanted
to have this bishop protected but now
with Queen d3 Knight h5 makes much much
more sense because Knight f4 would gain
the Tempe so after a knight h5 she put
g3 which I do think it was the most best
way to go because after Jeter is
protecting this square and even though
it's opening up some other weaknesses
for the bishop for example it's choosing
between one weakness or the other like
the only way to stop my Knights jumping
to it f4 is to play this g3 so after g3
I feel like Bishop h3 is pretty
automatic so you just glanced at it and
you do wish I wish tree rook e1 rook t1
I don't really think there's much of a
difference between rook e1 or t1
so after rook e1 I wanted to try and
attack a bit more so when after this
Bishop h3 I know for a fact I'm not
gonna bring this Bishop back to e6 to
try to short castle so I might as well
just play Ric f8 and after rook F 8 I am
already pressuring f2 I might want to
play Queen f6 I might want to try and
push for f3 square I have different
ideas and district belongs to f8 I might
not be sure where should I put the Queen
but the rook I know it should be an f8
she continued developing which is very
reasonable
and here I had the idea to try and play
g5 and my idea was to have this queen in
this file and then trick with something
like Knight f4 so the idea is for
example before Queen f6 I attack your
pawn first you defend it with Queen
which because I mean rookie two
shouldn't really be working Lisa well
Bishop g4 also the Knight f4 would be
stronger Queen III now Queen g6 I want
to play Knight to f4 and if I get the
chance to play Knight f4 if you take it
with the pawn I take with my Jeep on and
attacking your Queen and giving your
check yeah it's not pretty so after
Queen g6
I feel like Bishop f1 might have worked
as well because now Knight f4 you just
continue something like this and I like
blacks position I still keep pressure
and even though the bishops are
exchanged off my knight is pretty strong
here and you can't really take it off
right now so another way to go instead
of Bishop f1 was to simply play King is
one not every move is supposed to be
crazy ideas king is Ron just blocks this
idea of Knight f4 GF 4 GF 4 check so
after King s1 I pretty much realized
that Knight f4 is kind of a dream that
might not come true anymore so I decided
to relocate the pieces especially
because I can't improve this Queen over
here this Queen belongs closer to the
king so I was trying to like dug up dig
up some some pathway for my queen I can
actually what do you think I should do
I've already said that I want to put my
queen closer to White's King and I've
already said that the knight on h5 isn't
really serving much purpose anymore
yep
bringing the knight to f6 yeah that's
pretty much the idea maybe not
necessarily I mean Knight f6 also
follows with the idea of Knight g4 right
so then the main thing to think about
after 9 F 6 is that your opponent has to
quickly stop 94 with most likely
something like f3 which is actually what
happens in the game and then yes you put
the well ok about the move but I feel
like that's something that was going to
happen regardless because your queen
isn't it's not enough to just be in h5
you want it to be on each tree so I'm
the bishop here isn't really doing
anything as much anymore it's keeping
the tabs on g2 and f1 squares but it can
always come back so something like
Bishop t7 I'm not actually going to take
a takes before and rook takes a 4
because it would just open up more ideas
and space for white in the Queen side
but it's at least giving the scares and
now why it has to think about okay now I
have to try and calculate about does
this work does that work so I feel like
we should be 7 was a pretty nice move
just at least psychologically so she
approached it with Bishop b5 and after
Bishop b5
I think Queen h5 was the right move I
could consider something like c6 but I
really didn't want to do c6 unless I
absolutely have to
because t6 opens up some squares for
maybe Queen b6 and gives ideas about d6
square so I wanted to try and keep this
Center to the Queen side as solid as
possible so Queen is 5
I do think that Bishop d7 was slightly
smarter than Rock f1 but it stills opens
up like I still have the idea to double
up the rooks and still continue with an
attack but I feel like this would have
been stronger for white just to try to
create more chances but after rookie f1
Queen is tree pretty immediately
kingi 195 this should also be pretty
automatically because your knight
doesn't really have any we're good to go
except for h5 and after it's five might
want to do something either four might
want to take this guy and I mean ideally
yeah I think if it was black to move
again Knight takes g3 let's say why did
something weird like taking over here
I think not g3 should be working and
then drew comes to f4 this should be
winning enough so that's the even though
they're like little tricks that most
likely your opponents wouldn't fall for
because they're very straightforward
it's also improving your position like
Queen on h3 is serving your nice purpose
knight on s5 is serving a good purpose
also it's opening up with some ideas and
trying to double the rooks up so she
played Queen e2 which I do think was the
best move or at least one of the best
ones to how does have a very nice idea
protecting the King least at this point
I realized that well there could also be
some Bishop d7 if I take which King
could be some queen bee fives and I
didn't really want to yep
oh sorry I didn't really want to deal
with the the hassles of giving my
opponent too many chances so I just
played c6 Bishop c4 Bishop d3 I don't
really think there's much difference
between Bishop c4 or Bishop d3 now
probably I could have tried to play rook
f6 and King g7 and rook rook a f8 and
attacking over here but again I didn't
really want to deal with something like
taking over here and some drug to b1 and
attacking I just didn't well maybe not
maybe saying I didn't want to deal with
isn't the best phrase but I didn't want
to give my opponent that chance to to be
able to attack me so I would have to
deal with it
so yeah that's why I took on before and
now King g7 I'm following up with the
idea that I want to double up my rooks
on the F file and she's also trying to
create some counter plays over here now
this is kind of a critical moment
because in the game she played rock f2
but according to computers Brooke a2 is
better and can you tell me why it's okay
if you can't but
so in the game she moved this rook up
but computer says this is better why do
you think
it's okay as soon as I show the next few
moves it will give you a clearer idea
why but yes I'm just keeping it keep it
in mind what do you think is the
difference between rock f 2 and root K 2
so just keep that question in mind as we
go in about two train moves it should
clear up so regardless of what let's go
let's go along with what she played in
the game she played rock F - what do you
think black should do
yeah
that is a very smart idea and that's
something that's coming up that's
something that both white and black are
thinking about but you can't prepare it
a little bit more because if Knight
takes g3 white will just take back the
night and queen g3 rook g2 and it's it's
still pretty nice but you can't prepare
it better how do you think you can
prepare it better
why would I think it's better if you
stick with a Nigerian idea just prepare
it Knight takes g3 better
so the idea the idea of 93 is very valid
but in order to prepare it better
something like g4 when you think about
something just say it so now what can't
really take back on g4 because of Bishop
g4 least of all brings my Bishop back to
the attack so something like f4 and what
now
you could do that but the problem is
that it keeps it creates more chances as
such as a five and it gives white a
chance to start attacking me and usually
these little things that you think
you're already winning but you give your
opponents slight chance to start
attacking you and things start going
sideways so I I've been trying to train
myself not to do that so
ef4 is one of those moves unless it's
absolutely winning and you can calculate
every little detail you shouldn't do it
because it gives the your opponent a
chance to start opening it up you said
let's move before what do you think we
should do yeah now it's the time g-form
was the preparation that we needed
because now after rook g2 now what do
you think you should do as black this
move is the difference between the
having the route to a 2 or to a 1
oh no that that is yeah that's right
that's wouldn't really be a sacrifice
would be a blunder you're right that's
not a good move
think about it a little more like so
this guy is here all alone with no
protection what do you want to do to it
attack it yeah
now with Queen Cersei three this is like
an intermediate move because ideally now
let's look at this position so if your
opponent plays okay if my opponent plays
route k2g 4f4 take take take for example
queen g2i this Queen c3 doesn't work
anymore even though I still have this
and it should still be pretty pleasant
for black to continue I don't have this
queen c3
yeah I came to d2 and stayed here that's
true
but yeah so we see the difference here
is that the Queen on g2 and the rook on
i2
we're here having to get to play Quincy
tree because after Queen citrine now I
can actually try and take this with the
rook because then again if rook e1 or
roof d1 or anywhere I can't really take
back with the pawn even though it looks
so amazing you're going where f3 g3
there's again this five ideas coming up
so it's double check so you're talking
about a 5 f3 double check
yeah see that's why I'm saying don't
give to your opponent chances you give
chances little mistakes happen
so you take back with the rook solid
strong you still have advantage even
those it's lights you have advantage and
see your queen is taking all these pawns
over here and that's actually what
happened in the game
I took pretty much all the pawns and now
I go for exchange of Queens why when you
have more material it's a good idea to
think about exchanging off the heavy
pieces it helps out the endgame there
are exceptions and sometimes you just
have a good attack and you can't win but
in this specific situation just imagine
if my opponent did take this guy I have
five parts to one night and one pawn
this should be more than enough to win
I'm gonna start pushing these pawns and
this roof is pretty misplaced so yeah
she she was pretty smart and didn't
really take it she went with Queen G
tree now I try to double up my rook also
in this specific situation we were all
built in super time trouble like playing
on seconds from what I remember and I do
believe that I something about a king
going to h1 or the check first and then
king yesh one because I remember that
after the game I was like oh she had
that and the reason is that if it was
black to weaken I want to play rock f2 I
want to exchange off these pieces and I
want to interred and game which is I
know I'm gonna safely win whereas here
you might have some little tactics
coming up even though I'm I don't really
see them right now but yeah
well that's good you're seeing the
little tactics good job Quinton quick
yeah yeah so yeah she could have thought
about something like English one so
that's rookie have two wouldn't really
mean as much because now maybe even can
take this since this guy spent and it
would create more crazy chances but in
the game she played Bishop e2 to attack
the g4 pawn and here I believe we
repeated well sorry I thought who
repeated I King d8 I was simply just
going for King c8 and I wanted to kick
the rook out and then after Bishop a6
I'm not gonna play King c8 anymore and
also King d8 the other idea is that I'm
simply getting rid of the pin that was
on my bishop because here there could be
some ideas with Bishop takes g4 but when
I move the King Bishop g4 doesn't work
anymore cuz of but my bishop is also
protecting it so she played Bishop a6 I
think she I don't really know what she
was what was her idea but another thing
is for example here I could think about
a movement such as Queen d2 but I
believe it wouldn't have worked because
of Bishop g4 and then you could think
about and move like rook f2 and then
there is this trick t7 and you see it's
already getting complicated
unnecessarily so yeah that's why a
simple move such as King d8 is enough to
win yeah so here she put Bishop a6 rook
F 2 I'm going for the exchange
and now again I took the one last pun
that was remaining I gave few checks and
now I'm going for a queen of tree rugby
- I think I there were other ideas that
I could have tried but this seemed to be
simple enough for a win and see here I
could think about something like
probably Bishop e6 with the idea Bishop
d5 I think that's actually pretty good
but I didn't want to leave this rook
hanging so I just I wanted to have it
protect it so it would avoid any kind of
blunders forgive - and I think Oh
crafter was a kind of a bad move because
after rook F - you just exchange it off
and this endgame is winning but anyways
this did this situation black is winning
anyways it's just a matter of how and
here was actually pretty fun for me see
you're pushing your pawns are still
trying not to blend they're keeping the
pawns are strong and like it's okay if
you give out this pawn but it's kind of
a good idea to keep the rest of them so
like if he or she took it doesn't really
like work just I will bring the King and
I'll keep pushing and the King has to
stay here where whereas the bishop can't
really stop these pawns and also well
yeah so a little bit longer and almost
resignation yeah this was actually
pretty cool I loved how my physician
looked this was even though she wasn't
the highest rated that I've beaten mmm
it was one of my most favorite games
because it just felt like such a clean
win I had some tactics I had some
strategy and it just it feels really
good also the fact that she won the
championship yeah so this was the first
game I wanted to show you
that's what once the next one unless
someone has a question yeah yeah early
in the opening I've I do remember that
she she definitely didn't expect a five
but I do remember that Queen D 394 I
feel like this was about time when she
was out of prep I think probably she
expected something like T six because
it's the safer way to go and it used to
be more common back in the days 2015 and
I feel like around here was when she was
out of prep after day five yeah because
I don't think Bishop g5 is actually a
good move because even up even if you
play Bishop III first should be like
better because I have to take and at
least I mean if my pawn is on h6 it
helps me I want to play g5 I want to
push but now I'm
it was just a feeling I had in the game
that she was out of prep when she quit
Bishop g5 but she definitely knew queen
d3 and yeah and 94 is not so hard to
decide between taking and c3 is also
pretty natural
so yeah anything else cool
so this game I was white and again 2015
but December this was in Catherine's
masters I do believe that I was the
lowest ranked there or like one of the
last one of the lowest ranks and rated
strengths yeah
Oh
now so yeah
we are gonna do at least until the some
part of this game and we're just gonna
like push through to the next one
because this is pretty interesting and
it is it did have a pretty interesting
end game as well so French
and that's right see you hate French
that she hates it I don't know why it's
so nice so
I feel like this night see tree is not
like lot of people point 92 but for me I
I look tough I used to be very weak in
French and I read the book that
primaries are negative about efore
versus like French
caro-kann silly though a bunch of stuff
and I liked it and I followed it became
my chest Bible for a few few months it
was pretty good book
and so yeah I used to be very afraid of
this this whenever I do believe it's
called whenever yeah I might be saying
it wrong
but yeah so there are many different
lines that black can go for black OD try
to do the c5 short Gaston
or I mean kind of have to do c5 there
are some like King f8 and stuff that I'm
not the biggest fan of it it's a little
confusing but well not after that book
so after c5 queen g4 is I mean it it's
something that works against both short
Casto and if Queen c7 and so I'm not
gonna get too detailed in the theory of
this I'm hoping that I could dedicate a
full month maybe a little more to go
into French opening as white in these
series but yeah so this could be premium
yeah so Queen c7 there are many
different lines one of them I do believe
that the the main main line is like
taking g7 rook c8 oops
and then like you just start taking
everything and that's a little crazy
I've played it I don't remember it move
by move I do know that what I generally
should be looking out for but
that wasn't that book so 2015 I was I
believed in the book I went by the book
yeah so Bishop t3 is actually what was
in the book and the idea is that
everybody kind of knows the little
itty-bitty details of taking and taking
at they've been playing it for years and
there's so much theory in it and it's
one way to run out of theory to run away
from theory and make your opponent to
run out of theory because Bishop d3 is
kind of again annoying
you're not going by what your opponents
always plays because it like even though
the friendly game black plays this a lot
of people more than 50% I want to say
more than 70% would take on g7 take on
a7 and it's just automatic so Bishop d3
just not letting your opponent have
that's free breath taking on d4 I did
what if there's a c4 here and there the
wait nope c4 is blender you can just
take on wait can you
sorry I'm mixing up my games c4 is a
move because if you take on g7 rook g8
if you take on age seven I mean you're
kind of giving up the piece but c4 is a
move and I do believe that I have some
games like that too
anyways so the idea is after CD for now
you can get to play 92 because if you
take there is the queen c3 check so you
are not free of that so 92 is the the
idea is you protect your C 3 square and
if they take like this now you can
simply just take back and if Queen f6
Bishop g5 it's pretty neat trick huh
yeah it's goodbye party for the Queen so
it has this little tricks that you
should black should watch out for
so these takes c3 Queen takes 3/7
rook comes take the other pawn take this
pawn now the idea that with h4 is you
could try to play something like we
should have a 4 first and if Queen f6
now something like h4 but I do believe
that's the wrong way to go there are
some Brooke G twos I think yeah now you
don't have this about 5 Bishop g5
because of well F 2 squared and I do
believe that in another game earlier and
I kind of mix up my opening oops and
then I learned from it so it's for now
the idea is when you do something else
such as 97 sorry keeps coming after 97
visible for now you get to do Bishop g5
the idea is if black plays something
like we need five you this should be
should be good right also something like
maybe f4 first now you're gonna move the
Queen if you don't go to h8 you move it
away again you can and the rook is
defenseless
so yeah it has all these little tricks
so after Bishop g5 I do believe that the
best move is Queen and eight and Queens
exchanged I I mean it's not technically
an endgame yet just because the Queen's
are off but you can see how this flow of
moves coming this pawn is already like a
baby Queen
this is something that you know you're
gonna keep pushing you do know that
that's why you're gonna go blonde castle
you do want to take this pawn you do
want to push these pawns as much as
possible so these are your just basic
ideas and how they think what should
proceed now she's like with what move
should you continue
quite a move what do you do
yeah why not it's up to you
you could take it first you could long
castle first you could push this fight
first
Wow right yeah sure why not
I mean it's coming up it's just a matter
of deciding if you want to do it first
or you want to take c3 first so I did
take it on CTV first and I do have the
idea to go here at least try to go to b5
and so a six to take away that idea
Huang Casto step 6
you see if it's white to move again I'm
gonna start pushing for G 4 X 5 so it is
a good idea to try and push the bishop
out because if you try something like 95
there could be this Bishop f6 even if
you take this with Czech Bishop the rook
is under attack you gotta move it now g4
could be coming up or simply you don't
well as black you don't really know how
to untangle your pieces but what do you
want to do with this Bishop so that's
probably why f6 was plate 95 attacking
this Bishop I really wanted to keep my
Bishop so hmm
also the other thing is after Bishop e2
this F 4 and then h5 g for it it's all
kind of flowing so yeah Bishop e2
another Knight to f5 still attacking all
my bishops and at this point I realized
that I can't keep running away with the
bishops
I mean I take theoretically I could and
then they take it could keep chasing or
it wasn't the right flow that's yeah so
I continued with
age five I do think I mean I think he
should have taken it I would have taken
this bishop if I was black just because
least of all it's creating and knowing
now how would I push no I can't really
push on g5 and it would disturb this
flow of loops that I had so I do think
93 should have been played but Bishop d7
all right is it a lot of time to move
this to the next one it is okay it is
that game I'm just saying sure alright
so how do you think you should proceed
here you want to start pushing apart
what yeah I agree
I think it's about time you could try to
protect this guy a little bit more but
okay yeah it makes sense right you want
to play Bishop before and then you want
to push the pawn after you see it's
different a little bit because now these
pawns are actually two paths pawns
rather than if the bishop was exchanged
over here then it wouldn't have been to
pass on it wouldn't have been as easy to
do but at the same time now black has a
can start doing stuff in the center so I
I mean my knife is under attack
so I played your Kasturi to defend it
and at the same time I want to play g4 I
want to bring this rook I do believe
that something like king of seven was a
slightly more accurate just because how
it's unfolded in the game but the idea
is that black has to do something in the
center and queen size because if black
doesn't then if black is just sitting I
do believe the right term is sitting
duck right yeah I'm just gonna push
these pawns and keep pushing and well
it's very nice for me very annoying for
him might come up with something but
yeah very unlikely
so black should be trying to do stuff in
the Queen side and center
that's why 96 now I didn't really I felt
quite unsafe to allow something like d4
especially since so here if d4 now I
have knight to come to e4 so
if t4i could do something like 94 so I
feel like the fact that 96 was actually
pretty smart
now d4 is a real threat and I knew that
d4 was coming up regardless of what I do
so I wanted to relocate the knight
faster to maybe try and do Knight e4 so
if d4 Knight g4 that was the initial
idea
d4 takes away that idea but also it
creates a weakness in e4 square f3 and
now Knight c4 trying to go first
III and I do believe that this was
getting a little dangerous for me so
that's why I eliminated a nice you see
even though like this bishop would be
such an monster let's say for example in
e4 protecting so many squares and trying
to go for g4 g5 it's not worth this I
mean it's not worth it to let this night
to be that strong so I decided to
exchange it off just protecting c2 I
think this was the the smarter choice to
go even though it would give me like
this pass pawn I think this was this was
the way to fight it
now you see earlier when I mentioned
King to f7 instead of [ __ ] 7 I don't
want to remember the position but if the
King was already on f7 black was like a
tempie up we don't have to waste that
time here trying to bring that came
because it was kind of obvious the King
I eventually would have to come and
protect stuff over here so pretty
obvious G 4 3 2 these are all like
obvious moves still pretty office I do
think h6 would have worked but I really
really wanted this night to not just die
here
so night of - now I might want to go to
g4 might want to go to even efore might
want to go to d3 so
I block the rook and the tack you see
like a little move like 9f2 might not be
your first choice but all of your pieces
are doing something you're both of your
groups are in the best position your
pawns are ready to be pushed it's more
like just the knot I think that's high
set orange e4 to attack e5 so yeah 9f2
993 also this pawn is defenseless
so yeah
yeah that's the idea its opponents move
but that is the idea
good job so yeah I mean if you do
something like whoops King f5 shouldn't
be working because I mean - baby Queens
so my opponent decided to kind of give
up the exchange yeah I love you see
fishes still need some some technique to
win it it is winning position but you
need to know how to follow up with it
you can't just do something like I mean
technically you could but you would be
leaving your pawns defenseless so it is
a good idea to just take it slow player
of g3 defend your g5 pod now you want to
do it seven so black has to go and I
thought Black has to go back but now you
attack the bishop it's just like trying
out different things but the idea is
that you need your rook to be in eighth
rank there so you can start giving
checks and start pushing for Queens now
you want to do rook f6 and then you want
to follow it with maybe Ricketts tree
and then g6 okay
probably this this should also be losing
because of g7 and g8 is unstoppable
but kingís wife just made it a little
easier yep
and she gave up around now so yeah this
was actually pretty interesting I wish
we could go a little bit more into
detail about the endgame but it was
pretty straightforward right you knew
what you were doing and you just kept on
pushing for it yeah that's all I had for
today's chess and psychology I hope you
learned some new tricks and yeah let's
do more in games
[Music]